you know with the family that you guys
have like 15 kids between all of you
yeah do you ever find yourself coming
out to an event like this like bringing
all the kids like how easy is that for
guys there's no what the answer Stampede
wherever we go yeah you know I mean it's
it's I think Taylor has six kids I have
four eyes against three like it's it's a
family as a big deal for us but that's
just because you know we had a great
experience growing up playing music
together and though we never consciously
yes yeah you know being brothers was
never like a requirement but it it's
sort of it's been a great thing for us
helps to keep us together for 27 years
of course it seems to me like a musical
family like that with so much talent to
pass down too fast down to all these
kids like it would be a party you know
every time you guys get together it must
be like that well it's loud I mean we we
grew up playing music and the way you
got your point across is you just made
your voice louder and louder and louder
and the next guy so I mean yeah it's a
lot of fun I mean it's definitely the
cousins are closed I mean it's
interesting of course they all have
their dads that do something together in
their business and travel suits it's a
unique situation we're not sure what
damage we will have caused them until
they grow up and blame us for things
that happen along the way for therapy
yeah I always say that's you all paper
later I mean for us it's always been
about music it's always been about doing
something you love and I think if
anything with with all our kids you just
hope they see that example because hey
if you if you're willing to work hard if
you're really did you know to fight for
it and then you have a shot at doing
something you care about
yeah I'm trying to convince them not to
do music I mean I guess I didn't say
that you need to do music just something
that you enjoy
but if they were to follow down that
path I mean it seems like such a natural
thing is there do you have like a list
of advice just like waiting to go well I
mean there's there's all kinds of things
obviously you get to best on your
pitfalls to them and be like hey here's
the way you should do this you know
don't make that bad move or don't make
that but up ultimately you've gotta let
them find their way and dad like any
good dad is there to you know give you a
little advice when you need it and pick
you up when you hold that
so who's like the coolest uncle then I
don't know we all kind of a scenario
probably different things you know I
think it's like the Baby Whisperer yeah
zach is the gamer yeah and then you know
I'm there for your teen years probably
the most likely to teach you how to
swing an axe let's talk about in real
life in Eliza's now when people get on
your website yes so tell me about that
decision yeah well you know for us we
realized years ago that the the most
powerful thing we had as a band was our
connection to our fans and so we started
investing in the idea of building our
own community not just selling through
record stores but actually asking people
to become members of sort of the Hanson
world and so every year we're releasing
music exclusively to members and so at
this point we're at least you know 10
albums to the public but we've released
just as much music that's only gone to
this core group of Hanson fans and it
allows us just we do kind of different
things with those projects than you
would with another record because you
know it's not going out to casual fans
it's going on to people who are invested
deeply in what you do and so you take
kind of cool risks and a lot of those
projects are themed with ideas at the
forefront like we're gonna make it in
this kind of way we're gonna write about
these kind of things and so in real life
is the latest one that just came out in
me
the community side of it is also
encourages us to take chances because
you have people that know all the
details they know the ins and the outs
and ultimately if you're if you're
wanting to come out to a show buy ticket
buy a record these days you're probably
one step away from why should be a part
of this community I should go to the
special cool stuff that's happening so
yeah people can find out we've been
sharing clips of music just to sort of
invite people into that project all
month long so when you're putting an
album together when you put an EP
together is it a collection of songs
that you've just worked on or is it you
know in real life this is the message we
want to put forward what what is it well
you know as as we've reached different
milestones in our career you begin to
look at records in a different way and
so as a band now we've been together for
27 years when we hit 25 we said you know
what whether we like it or not we've got
kind of a legacy and we can we can look
at our projects with that kind of like
oh you're now reaching multiple
generations of music fans when you got
look at the audience
there's moms and dads and kids and
grandpas and grab
people who have been they they came to
their very first concert when they were
7 with their mom or their dad and now
they're bringing their kids and it's so
you know that's when we decided to do
the the last big album we did was called
string theory and we've put together 22
songs with an orchestra with an amazing
arranger who's won Oscars and been
touring the world with that you know
playing in a Sydney Opera House and like
all these amazing places but more and
more I think we think about records from
the point of view of telling stories and
connecting with people and that becomes
kind of the driving force and how you
collect those songs is really about the
story you want to tell you want to go to
a special place and write all the music
there you want to go write it with cool
different people and build this sort of
tapestry but it's more just about
telling stories yeah you know when
people are looking in from the outside
and they see you they think the legacy
of Hanson the thing about the music that
they've loved growing up and what they
think like a rock star life is like what
is real life for you guys I mean the
truth is there's a lot of things we get
to do that we
normal that is kind of crazy I mean we
do get to travel the world we do get to
you know stay in beautiful places try
cool food see huge crowds but so much of
what we do is also you know we talk
about it's like the dumpsters and alleys
tour like you go to the most beautiful
places you know most you know you get to
visit crazy and you're seeing back doors
back alleys dumpster entrances even the
Sydney Opera House dumpster so I mean
it's a strange you know so much what you
do is is preparing for each of those
nights and you know giving something new
to an audience even though it may be old
a hat for you you may have some that
song a thousand times but it's you know
it's not all you know fireworks and you
know having you know parties and
champagne it's really you know it's kind
of a blue-collar life you know you can't
farm it out and be like executive like
executive memo do good show you know you
have to show up and every night sweat it
out and give to that audio the kind of
music we make you have to death right
yeah I mean there's always we we would
be doing this whether anybody showed up
or not and I think that's really the
heart of what we're about like we we
sort of have found a way to justify
something that is a requirement for us
to make music and so to have fans that
want it follow you and stick with you
and go through highs and lows with you I
think is really what makes it you just
kind of an incredible thing that's cool
what's what's the one thing that you
would say it so like teenage Hanson I
don't have you thought of this a lot
maybe you get that lot but I want to
know you know I think the thing that I
would tell to like to young people who
are thinking about doing music and so to
some extent young Hanson is more like
this is a job where you live and die by
the risks you're willing to take and and
that's everything from you know when you
go in every day to write a song like do
you have it do you have a great song in
you that's a real like personal risk or
standing on stage and like asking people
to be fans and trust you and so don't be
afraid to take risks if you really want
to do this as a life then get kind of
get comfortable with that
the butterflies and the insecurities and
then like know that when you're feeling
that there's a good chance you're in the
right place right means you care right
yeah yes yeah it is